have you ever heard the phrase rhinos
are just chubby unicorns would you
believe me if I said that that was
actually rooted in fact one of the
earliest examples dating back to 2600
BCE is the Bine unicorn from the indis
valley civilization in South Asia the
creature was described as a four-legged
grazing animal of a heavy build with a
single horn protruding from its head
contemporary Scholars have linked these
depictions to the alasm theum which is
basically just a big fuzzy Rhino and
then there's the car from Islamic Legend
while the depiction of the caradon has
changed somewhat the description of it
provided by polymath albaron speaks of a
scaly Buffalo with a horned nose again
he's talking about a rhino so the next
time someone tries to tell you that
unicorns don't exist just take them to a
zoo although I think you'd have a hard
time finding a rhino with a glittery man
that poops rainbows now if only I could
figure out where that myth came from